luca toni peperoni luca toni ormai per
me numero uno non era uno non ti faccio
vincere scherzando il video alla ragazza
che windows
oggi chi è meno di milos qui che ma cosa
vuoi che gli ha scritto quel libro è
oggi per niente siamo su giraffe
volleyball che sarebbe pallavolo con le
giraffe lorenzo ho capito cosa ha detto
le giraffe che ne sapete tutti hanno
collo lungo e quindi una questione di ma
perché un mio video possiamo fare io
leggi stai zitto jl i capi sono le tue
lettere sono già ed è il kick ass
ma mi lasci il ma lei vai vai
riferimento siamo tornati al momento c'è
un problema aspetta aspetta come qualità
si aspetta
ma sono quasi mastai perdo non ci sono
fisicamente io ah ah ah ah è
difficilissimo a ti fai male ma allora
mi passa tutto
ma se uno mi fai mi fai spazi sulla
tastiera bene di sinistra ma ho vinto ho
vinto io grazie amici sono forte mi
merito gli iscritti palmi che fischia
uno consentito come no bravissimo
bravissimo ma bravo amico si no vanno
male sono tasse a caso due sì dai
aspetta per evadere questa spiaggia
oppure vi sono quattro tasti così lui
con il gioco entra
bellissimo siamo invertiti ora io sono a
sinistra ma il lucca 6 per me lei il
numero uno se momento anche me stai
volendo ma lo sa il momento me come ti
diverti tu ti sei divertene sono a
questo mondo non ce la faccio non vedo
niente lacrime agli occhi
incredibile a lui un'altra volta il
nostro primo video abbia fatto 40
partite due anni neanche uno sembra che
abbiamo no non siamo sanissimi omaggiato
sushi prima si saremmo settati dopo sei
ore per giocare sta roba
cerchiamo vita mia testa perché da dover
kakà o dai manicomi femore
ma allora che gioco studio io mi son
uomo e poi come bruciarsi omesso
joystick perché tu poi in movimento le
frecce scala prometto che non usano mai
questo tempo dai pendolari tranquillo e
non va guarda che non va non va non va
definire throw di così no hai fatto di
una finta allucinante cosa anche per il
merletto ciò la caccia quanto stupido
stadio è bellissimo
e vabbè fai tu da aipo 28 pure io ma ce
li trovi io li alza la testa con la
barra spaziatrice che raccomandare dai
cos'è lo fai fisiche amici aiuto
bravissimo che sono stati fatto
gravissimo
no guarda che tu puoi andare io no ma
cos'è questo
ma devi fare questa cosa ma sofferente
ma sono ma fate fare decidi tu non ho
capito perché grazie non toccare le
freccette e cosa valgo di sinistra ora
io sono qua adesso sai giocare non è
colpa sua
sul mio punto diventato dato sempre il
parco demonio e chi ray pileio giorno
veramente lento e lo so ma poche
schiaffone
mamma mia mamma alla battuta commissioni
sbagliando no cosa hai fatto da eva
[ __ ] 3 a 3 ma mi sa che sudata dai
che l'abbiamo come questa così forte
questo incredibile caso veramente
fortissimo perché se va beh è veramente
lento
[Musica]
numero uno niente raga è difficile però
ci potrò fare tutti batterò con la
tastiera mi sento a bastardo no no è
buono
no non assolve testa con di calzona
stronzo bellissimo mi piace allora
ascoltami dei palleggi ormai il collo
dov'è finito era sotto terra al colony
maurizio costanzo unitarie boni taleban
ma va a cagare chi schiacciata ho fatto
la talmente sbilenca l'era che era
imprendibile
mamma vive schiaffo nel misto riaprendo
che schiaffoni giusto giusto l'ultimo
line
vai dai wonderful girato grazie amici ce
n'è solo uno di champions iscrivetevi
bella
[Musica]
mammamia alimenti voilà basta